[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soit il est bienvenus sur France 24 elle
a une ce soir un contingent kenyan dans
l'est de la République démocratique du
Congo près d'un millier de soldats vont
être déployés progressivement pour
lutter contre le M23 un déploiement qui
intervient plusieurs mois après
l'annonce de la mise en place d'une
force régionale par la Communauté des
États d'Afrique de l'Est nous serons à
nairobie dans ce journal et nous ferons
réagir notre invité le ministre des
Affaires étrangères congolais Christophe
Lula
cette annonce de cessation d'hostilité
entre le gouvernement éthiopien et les
rebelles du Tigré un accord sous l'égide
de l'Union africaine après Tori en
Afrique du Sud il intervient après deux
ans de conflits les détails dans ce
journal
la condamnation de l'ex commandant
rebelle libérien Kunti Camara par la
cour d'assises de Paris il a écopé de la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité pour
des actes de barbarie commis pendant la
première guerre civile au Liberia
on commence donc par ces images du
président kenyan William Routot qui
remet le drapeau du pays au contingent
qui va combattre dans l'est de la
République démocratique du Congo une
cérémonie qui marque le lancement
officiel de la mission ces hommes vont
servir au sein de la Force régionale est
africaine déployée pour lutter contre
les groupes armés dans les deux qui vous
dans leur ligne de mire les rebelles du
M23 la correspondance un aérobie de
Bastien renouilles
il s'agit d'une mission pour protéger
l'humanité ce sont les mots graves du
président kenyan William auto des propos
tenus devant les troupes kenyan qui vont
être envoyés dans l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo il s'agit d'une
mission extrêmement importante il était
urgent que la communauté astafricaine
réagisse pour protéger la région contre
les criminels contre les terroristes et
contre les groupes armés ce sont les
mots du président kenyan on ne sait peu
de choses à propos des troupes qui vont
être déployés sur place il y avait
plusieurs centaines de soldats présents
à la cérémonie ce mercredi matin mais le
gouvernement refuse de dire combien
seront Ré déployés sur le terrain et
c'est officiellement pour des raisons de
sécurité ce que l'on sait c'est qu'ils
devront traverser l'Ouganda pour se
rendre dans la ville congolaise de
bounagana à la frontière avec luganda
une ville qui est aux mains du M23
actuellement il y a d'ailleurs déjà près
de 200 soldats gagnants selon nos
informations au niveau de cette
frontière qui ont préparé depuis des
semaines l'arrivée des troupes envoyées
ce jour depuis Nairobi combien de temps
vont-ils rester sur place impossible de
le dire pour l'instant ils ont un mandat
de 6 mois mais un mandat qui pourrait
être renouvelée si nécessaire en marge
de cette cérémonie le président kenyan
s'est entretenu avec son homologue
burunday et variston daichimié qui est
d'ailleurs le président en exercice de
la Communauté Est Africaine le président
Burundi a parlé à tous ces homologues de
la région ce mercredi et ce pour
organiser une grande réunion entre chef
d'État est africain et chef des armées
et ce afin d'organiser la riposte contre
les groupes armés dans l'est de la
République démocratique du Congo
et on parle justement de la situation
dans l'est de la République démocratique
du Congo avec notre invité Christophe
Lutundula ministre congolais des
Affaires étrangères merci d'être avec
nous en direct de Kinshasa alors avant
de vous faire réagir sur le déploiement
du contingent-aignan j'aimerais que nous
fassions un état des lieux quelle est la
situation à l'heure où l'on parle dans
l'est de la République démocratique du
Congo ou le M23 progresse
quotidiennement
la situation bien sûr tendue c'est une
guerre ce n'est pas les trois qui
progresse c'est l'armée rwandaise sur le
couvert d'un 23
alors le M23 progresse progresse c'est
un c'est un fait il progresse sur
notamment sur le territoire du du
rochourou donc comment vous accueillez
l'annonce du déploiement des forces
kenyanes qui a été faite aujourd'hui
oui vous avez dit le 23 progrès
mais notre armée n'est pas absente et le
résiste aussi partout on est le 23
attaqué avec l'armée rwandaise ils n'ont
pas gagné ce qui est en train de se
faire ou ce qui a commencé aujourd'hui
ça entre dans la ligne droite des
engagements que des chefs d'État de la
région ont pris engagement qui ont été
avalisés par la même conférence
de chefs d'État et de gouvernement de la
Communauté économique d'Afrique de l'Est
et je précise aussi que l'armée
kenyane ne sera pas seul au front il y a
des éléments de notre armée des phares
d'essai et il y a aussi l'armée
burundaise qui est déjà là ce n'est que
normal
alors
vous votre pays accuse le Rwanda d'armée
les rebelles du M23 quels sont les
preuves de vos accusations aujourd'hui
par le
comité conjoint de la de la communauté
de la conférence internationale sur la
région de grands lacs ces mécanisme
conjoint a fait aussi des rapports qui
établissent et enfin est-ce qu'il y a
encore de doute de leur cœur nous avons
déjà appréhender des éléments de l'armée
rwandaise que nous avons remis entre le
mail médiateur le président de l'Angola
le président Laurence je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est débat n'est plus de
mise le président Kagame lui-même a la
tribune de la science unie au mois de
septembre dernier dans les cadres de la
70e session de l'Assemblée générale
sans argument se contenter de dire que
il n'y a plus de réclamination à faire
maintenant alors vers une solution qui
est possible et enfin et enfin vous
savez que toute la communauté
internationale en tout cas toutes les
institutions internationales qui se sont
pensées sur le dossier ont demandé à la
RDC de négocier avec l'Ouganda et le
Rwanda ouais je veux plus que ces pays
ont concernés alors justement
l'ambassadeur du Rwanda dans votre pays
c'est un il a quitté la RDC lundi
après-midi la voix de la diplomatie
est-elle totalement rompue avec le
Rwanda
écoutez nous sommes des voisins
condamnés à vivre par la nature j'allais
dire par Dieu
notre problème je dirais c'est qu'il
faut pour nous la RDC c'est de créer de
conditions d'un vrai dialogue un
dialogue sincère un dialogue efficace et
ses conditions nous les avons toujours
répété 1 la cessation des activités
criminelles du groupe terroristes M23 2
le retrait de main 23 de toutes les
localités
occupées 3 l'arrêt total de tout soutien
au M23 par le Rwanda sans condition sans
délai et enfin le retour des congolais à
leur domicile voilà
dès lors que ce cadre est réuni que tout
est revenu dans l'ordre normal nous ne
voyons pas pourquoi on peut ne pas
dialoguer dans tous les cas nous faisons
confiance aux médiateurs désignés par
l'Union africaine le président
Joao Lorenzo de l'Angola et nous sommes
à sa disposition il a dit à quelques
jours à Dakar qui prendra des
initiatives dans ce sens-là alors là la
population dans l'est du pays
et trolls preuve que le M23 continue à
progresser c'est qu'on 11 jours l'ONU a
comptabilisé 50000 déplacés qui fuient
les combats n'est-ce pas aussi un échec
de l'état de siège ou le par le
président Tshisekedi pour sécuriser la
région
nous n'avons jamais compris pourquoi on
tient toujours ce discours là partout au
monde lorsque il y a une guerre sur une
guerre d'agression le premier mécanisme
auquel les étapes recours c'est le
mécanisme constitutionnait que l'état
des sièges que destiné à créer des
conditions objectifs de maintien d'un
minimum de l'ordre public de la
sécurisation de population et de
motivation et de Topal sur un petit
récit de force armées on s'attaque à
l'état de chez y a-t-il un autre
mécanisme en dehors de ces mécanismes
qui est constitutionnel sur le contrôle
du Parlement le problème c'est pas
l'état des sièges madame le problème
c'est l'agression notre armée il faut le
dire fait face à deux armées
conventionnelles plus un groupe
individus de terroristes aucune armée au
monde ne peut gagner par un claquement
de doigts devant une situation comme
celle-là le voyant soldat nous aide
soldats sont en train de se donc ce
n'est pas un problème d'état de ciel
d'ailleurs on est en train de se
demander si ce qui insiste sur l'état
d'essai ne veulent pas tout simplement
créer un boulevard pour que les ennemis
envahissent le pays comme ils veulent
non c'est pas ça
et
votre message quel est votre message à
la population et à ses déplacer qui qui
ne cesse de fuir et qui ne voit pas le
bout du tunnel
écoutez madame le réflexe normal de
notre humain lorsqu'il y a un danger
devant lui c'est de s'abriter quelque
part donc c'est naturel qu'est-ce que
nous disons nous disons que le
gouvernement de la République par tous
les moyens défendra avec le soutien de
Congolais qui sont aujourd'hui mobilisés
au-dessus de présenter ce qui dit autour
de l'armée nous gagnerons c'est le son
que des batailles c'est pas la guerre
une bataille on peut la gagner à un
moment donné on peut la perdre un autre
ce qui compte pour nous c'est la
victoire finale et tant sur le plan
diplomatique ça bouge que sur le plan de
la mobilisation populaire nous n'avons
aucun doute que nous allons gagner je
nous disons congolais ce n'est qu'une
pas si difficile comme tous les peuples
du monde
encodés dans dans l'histoire donc nous
ne baissons pas de la gare le président
a dit à la face du monde et quel qu'en
soit le prix nous allons gagner nous
allons continuer à protéger de notre
pays merci beaucoup monsieur votre votre
message est passé merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et et j'ajoute que
demain jeudi nous recevrons à Alain
moukoura Linda porte-parole adjoint du
gouvernement rwandais
ce Cécile feu se cesser le feu entre le
gouvernement Ethiopien et les rebelles
du Tigre et il a été signé sous l'égide
de l'Union africaine après Tori en
Afrique du Sud les belligérants se sont
accordés sur une trêve après deux ans de
conflit l'espoir d'une paix durable et
toutefois fragile d'autres Trèves
avaient été signés avant d'être violée
kalidoussi
le début d'une nouvelle ère pour
l'Éthiopie c'est par ces mots que
l'Union africaine s'est réjouit de
l'accord de cessation des hostilités
entre le gouvernement éthiopien et les
rebelles du tigre
les deux parties au conflit éthiopien
ont formellement accepté la cessation
des hostilités ainsi que le désarmement
systématique structuré harmonieux et
coordonnées
[Musique]
un accord également salué par les
rebelles du tigre
en ce qui concerne les deux parties nous
avons fait des concessions douloureuses
car il est bien plus important de
répondre aux souffrances de notre peuple
que de faire des concessions oui nous
avons fait des concessions parce que
nous avons établi la confiance et nous
devons nous assurer que tout le monde
s'appuie rapidement sur cette confiance
le conflit a débuté en novembre 2020
quand les dirigeants d'un groupe rebelle
le front de libération du peuple du
Tigré critique le gouvernement qui tente
selon lui de centraliser le pouvoir il
reproche également un traité de paix
conclu par Addis-Abeba et le voisin
Erythréen concernant un territoire
contesté en réponse en septembre 2020
les rebelles du Tigré organisent des
élections régionales un acte jugé
illégal par les autorités éthiopiennes
deux mois plus tard le premier ministre
aby-hamed accuse les rebelles d'attaques
contre les camps de l'armée et lance une
offensive en mars 2022 un cessé le feu
est conclu mais cinq mois plus les
affrontements reprennent si le bilan du
conflit reste inconnu l'ONU estime cette
guerre responsable de près de 500 000
morts plus de 2 millions d'estopiens ont
été déplacés et des centaines de
milliers en proie à la famine
a condamné mercredi l'accès commandant
rebelle kuntikamara la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité pour des actes
de barbarie pendant la première guerre
civile au Liberia et pour s'être rendue
complice de crimes contre l'humanité en
facilitant des viols à l'énoncer du
verdict l'accusé est resté impassible
verdict a été rendu après 9 heures de
délibéré
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'Afrique rester avec nous l'info
continue sur France 24
[Musique]
Stargate c'est un campus de startup
africain situé en plein cœur de
l'écosystème du savoir et l'innovation
du m6p nous hébergeons une dizaine de
programmes qui vise à accompagner les
start-up dans leur lancement et dans
leur développement on intervient sur
l'amont de la chaîne et la Val de la
chaîne en intervient sur de l'éducation
et de la sensibilisation
d'entrepreneuriat on fait de la
préincubation de l'incubation mais on
est aussi sur de l'accélération sur de
la mise en relation avec les
investisseurs sur cette partie avale il
y a quelques années l'innovation
l'éducation à la technologie c'était des
points faibles au Maroc aujourd'hui on
est en train de rattraper en fait ce
retard à travers ce genre de projet tous
l'écosystème est impacté le pays les
chercheurs les étudiants les
entrepreneurs nous en tant que Stargate
ce sont les intérêts des entrepreneurs
concerts en premier et finalement quand
on sert les intérêts des entrepreneurs
ils sont contents ils reviennent et donc
ça fait un cercle vertueux en quelque
sorte il y a un objectif de positionner
en fait notre écosystème à
l'international lui donner beaucoup plus
de visibilité aujourd'hui on a plutôt
20% seulement de non marocains parce
qu'on a démarré en plein covid qu'on
avait beaucoup de mal à faire venir ces
gens là mais voilà mais on a quand même
une représentation de 15 pays africains
non marocain en misant sur des piliers
comme l'éducation la technologie ou
encore l'innovation nous sommes en train
de bâtir l'Afrique de demain et
d'augmenter sa compétitivité à
l'international
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]